what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
trying to get it together after the last
video where I almost cried and I will be
talking about the latest twist in the
seven that Lisa and story in the
previous chapters we got multiple clear
hints that the defeat of the demon king
has disrupted the balance of light and
darkness and that something ominous will
happen as a result in this chapter we
got more information about this new era
that is coming after the era of the gods
and we learned that this new era is not
an era of peace and happy endings rather
this is an era of chaos and I don't know
about you but introducing an era of
chaos at this point sure doesn't sound
like the beginning of an epilogue to me
rather it sounds like the beginning of a
new mysterious arc and so let's dive
into all of the information that we have
so far in order to determine what will
happen next in this new arc and where
the story will be going from here if you
enjoyed the $0.70 content on this
channel and you want us to keep it going
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you happen to be
new to anime uproar please don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications a big
thank you to all of our anime or patrons
who make videos like this one possible
with constant youtube de monetization
fake claims and strikes and now Coppa
patrons really are more important than
ever thank you guys so much
and finally this video will of course
contains seven deadly sins spoilers
we're talking about the latest
developments in the story way beyond the
anime so please proceed with caution
you have been warned the cover of
Chapter three three four shows the
divine acts Rita stuck in the ground and
the words the mightiest of all's final
gift I'm gonna be honest seeing Rita
like this in the ground on its own
without anyone to carry it really hit me
right in the fields and this page also
made me wonder right away what kind of
gift are we talking about as the chapter
begins the Sun finally comes out in all
its glory
following the epic battle against the
demon
and naturally all of Britannia is
overjoyed the people of Britannia
realized what the sunshine means the
battle against the demon king has ended
and the seven deadly sins managed to win
the enormous ominous magic that came
from the demon king is gone and
everything is back to normal as if
nothing was ever wrong in the first
place
perhaps this is the final symbolic gift
that the cover page was talking about
ESCA norse ultimate sacrifice brought
back the son and banished the darkness
and this is deeply symbolic because Eska
nor was after all the master of the Sun
the legendary Big Daddy sunshine and he
is still and always will be the Big
Daddy of our hearts Dreyfuss Hendrix and
Gaia and Jericho all rushed back to
Leonys where News has already reached
King Batra that the seventh of these
sins defeated the demon king and that
Elizabeth is safe everyone in the
capital is celebrating and they decide
to prepare a big celebration for the
sins king Bartra even declares that this
day will become a new holiday in
Britannia and a festival will be held to
mark the monumental occasion however it
appears that the messenger did not tell
the king that as Kannur died during the
course of the battle so while everyone
is happy and celebrating most of them
seemed blissfully unaware that s Connor
sacrificed his life in order to make all
of this possible
but Gill Thunder is visibly shaken due
to the loss of s Kannur and he walks
away from the celebration his best
friend's house er and Gamora follow him
and together they discuss Eska norse
ultimate sacrifice crea Mora is humbled
by s Connors noble sacrifice and how he
could smile while risking his life for
his friends this is not something that
just anyone could do and Houser Ponder's
whether he could also one day reach the
greatness and glory of someone like
esken or not bloody likely Houser but
good luck my dude the three holy Knights
decide to raise a glass or rather bottle
and toast the epic life of Eskin or RIA
Moana then asks whether they are going
to drink at his house and it is clear
from his demeanor that he would rather
not go to his house
for some reason Gil asks whether there
is some specific reason that VMware
doesn't want them to come over and
Howser suggest that maybe Greer Mora has
a secret child that he is hiding from
them
grimoire are just kind of sighs and they
end up going to his house anyway where
they toast the seven deadly sins and
especially the Lyons sin of pride as the
three holy night sit around the table
Gillan Houser talking about the end of
the holy war and how great it is that
the demon king has finally been defeated
meanwhile crea Mora is being all shifty
and a thought bubble shows him thinking
about a woman who appears to be staying
at the house a woman whose presence he
clearly wants to keep secret from his
friends
Houser wonders what kind of new era
awaits them now that the era of the
demon king is over and Gil says that he
hopes it will be an era of peace but
then in that moment none other than the
thick yonder a Viviane emerges from the
other room and proclaims that when an
imbalance between the light and darkness
is created the era of chaos begins
Gillen Houser jumped from the table
shocked to see Vivian they thought that
she had been killed by looters shell
earlier on in the story however Vivian
explains that back when she was stabbed
by looters shell she was actually just
injured she was then saved by Greer
Morris father
Dreyfuss Dreyfuss felt bad for Vivian so
he had Hendrickson use recovery magic to
help her and then he took her back to
his house until she recovered since
Vivian is considered a traitor to the
kingdom Dreyfus couldn't treat her
injuries in the castle so he decided to
do it secretly at home and because of
dreyfuses kind act Vivian is now over
Gil and she is madly in love with
Dreyfus instead say what you will about
Vivian but she is a pretty solid yond
and a character and now that she is over
Gil she will probably be a lot less
annoying it's also pretty funny that
she's now into Graham or his dad and she
tells Greer Mora to call her mom from
now on who knew that Dreyfus was a DILF
a daddy Vivian would love to a fondle
apparently the magic of the goddesses
also removed Vivian's curse and I assume
that this happened when she was pierced
by literal sword so that's a bit of a
blessing in disguise right there
and okay I know overall thinking esken
or the mightiest human the master of the
Sun Big Daddy sunshine had to die but
Vivienne is brought back really naka bah
my dude I mean I don't mind Vivienne
like I said she is a pretty solid
yandere and now she's a DILF hunters so
that's pretty hilarious but I'm still
not over the loss of Eskin or that
previous chapter really broke my heart
and the lightheartedness of this chapter
is definitely a nice change of pace but
I am still reeling from what happened
last week nevertheless this chapter is
not all drinking and DILF hunters as
Vivian mentioned earlier the new era
that begins after the defeat of the
demon king is not an arrow of peace
instead it is an arrow chaos when Gil
asks Vivian what this means she tells
him that this is what Merlin always told
her when the balance between the light
and darkness crumbles it will mark the
end of the age of the gods and the
return of the era of chaos then
eventually the world will be reborn
we know that Vivian was at one point The
Apprentice of Merlin so it does make
sense that Merlin would share this type
of information with her the final scene
shows the sins in Leonys drinking and
eating Melly Otis appears to be toasting
a bottle with a symbol of the Sun on it
another symbolic shout-out to Eskin or
we then see Merlin her face still
scarred drinking what appears to be wine
and the final panel of the chapter shows
a none other than the body of King
Arthur himself and Arthur is still lying
motionless his chest pierced by the
legendary sword Excalibur the text on
the final panel reads the era begins to
shift forward with the King's death as
the catalyst so again instead of the
series ending the manga appears to be
teasing another arc instead of an era of
peace the defeat of the demon king has
ushered in an era of chaos but what
exactly will this new era bring what
will happen next we don't know for sure
but we do have enough information to
make some important speculations and
that is exactly what I will
be doing right now first off the idea
that the age of the gods has ended and
an era of chaos is about to follow
before the world is born anew is very
similar to Ragnarok in Norse mythology
if you watch my attack on Titan videos
then you surely heard me talk about
Ragnarok a lot but basically Ragnarok is
the apocalypse in Norse mythology a
great war erupt and even the gods are
killed and then the air of the gods ends
then out of that chaotic apocalyptic
situation a new world will emerge and a
man and a woman will survive the
apocalypse and they will repopulate the
earth and the world is born anew clearly
something along these lines is being
referenced here with King Arthur being
particularly important his death was
apparently a catalyst for what is about
to happen next so what will this age of
chaos bring what can we expect
we know that in Greek mythology chaos
was the first thing that existed before
the birth of the gods
so this apparent death of the gods will
usher in a return to an era of chaos
what this means exactly I cannot say at
the moment but it's safe to assume that
Hawkes mama isn't called the mother of
chaos for nothing this age of chaos will
clearly involve Hawkes mama and probably
also Hawk in some way although it's
difficult to say how exactly all of this
will tie in I predict that there will be
four key players in this era of chaos
Ark along with the main characters of
course those key players are the mother
of chaos King Arthur Merlin and
potentially the supreme deity this new
Ark will revolve around these four
characters in some way and if the return
to chaos comments can be taken at face
value then we are in for some pretty
apocalyptic events in the very near
future it is clear from this chapter
that Merlin knows some important things
that other people do not know from
Vivian's comments it is clear that
Merlin always knew that defeating the
demon king would lead to some
fundamental changes and that it would
usher in an era of chaos it was also
revealed in the previous chapter that
Merlin has certain sins and secrets that
she has lived with for over 3,000 years
and she is also the only sin who's back
story hasn't been explored in any
significant detail it seems to me that
Merlin is deeply connected to the era of
chaos and she is the common denominator
that connects the other three important
characters in the story Merlin was the
mentor of King Arthur and it is clear
that she had chosen him for something
big before his tragic death Merlin is
also the one who first told us that the
great Oshiro aka Hawks mama was none
other than the mother of chaos and of
course this happened in the seven deadly
sins prisoners of the sky movie finally
Merlin was the one who tricked the demon
king and the supreme deity in order to
gain blessings from both of them
so Merlin has a direct connection to all
three other important characters that I
think will be relevant in this arc
Arthur the mother of chaos and the
supreme deity Merlin also has secret
knowledge about all three of them that
no one else appears to have and I
predict that this information will
become crucial during this new chaos Ark
so now please let me know what you guys
think
what will this new era of chaos bring
and what can we expect next from this
arc in the story to me it definitely
seems like a brand new arc is being
teased and that it will revolve around
Merlin
Arthur Hawks mama and potentially
hopefully the supreme deity do you agree
and if not what do you think the next
arc will focus on also how about the
whole Vivian X Dreyfuss ship pretty damn
unexpected but I guess I don't hate it
especially since it's going to be so
hilariously awkward for Porgy amore if
you enjoyed this video and you want to
see us make more videos like this one
please leave a like to let me know and
if you happen to be new to anime uproar
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications if you want to get
notified for our videos and you don't
want to miss them it is very important
to go through the trouble of clicking
the bell and then selecting the option
to turn on all notifications feel free
to hit me up on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar for all the latest 7 Deadly
Sins news and updates I want to give a
big thank you to all of our anime upper
patrons for supporting our work and
making videos like this one possible
special thank you to all of our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh baby rain nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings ell dress $30.00 beat
accordion Anatoly Cassatt's ki DJ
Nathaniel alpha DL and on he'll crucify
get our the one tier patrons the ones
who stand above all other clans
including ingrid a a lowland out of
Maddy Mac makoto-kun Seth Cooper and the
world and you know he's serious because
he didn't say so wild doll if you enjoy
our videos and you feel that they
provide value for you please consider
becoming a patron even a single dollar
will give you access to our patron
exclusive discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see us space cowboys
[Music]